i'm happy to announce the official
opening of the ellen degeneres campus
of the diane fosse gorilla fund
ellen degeneres's long-awaited gorilla
conservation campus is finally open the
announcement comes four years after
portia derosi surprised her wife with
the ellen fund to help protect
endangered animals on her 60th birthday
it's your 60th birthday and this gift
had to be really special
and it had to
represent
who you are and what you really care
about not just now but what you've
always
cared about ellen and porsche's gift
enabled the diane fosse fund to build
the new campus just outside volcanoes
national park in rwanda where activists
and tourists alike will be able to join
the next generation of wildlife
conservationists
this campus it's going to be amazing
it's a place for everyone to visit it's
a state-of-the-art research facilities
for scientists and researchers from all
around the world to advance guerrilla
conservation and tourists can learn
about gorillas of course diane fosse was
famously portrayed by sigourney weaver
in the film gorillas in the miss the
late conservationist originally
established her fun in 1967 in an effort
to save endangered mountain gorillas
from poaching and destruction of their
habitat when i see my name next to diane
fossey's name on this campus that we
built is such an honor